the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lesson today is called the
inverse logarithm and what it will do
among other things is give us a very
nice chance to revisit inverse functions
in general only now applied specifically
to the natural logarithm function that
we talked about last time so I call
today's lessons I say inverse logarithms
and to see what's coming up here simply
recall that last time we invented so to
speak a new function called the natural
log of X this had nothing to do with
exponents it was what this was the
function whose derivative with respect
to X was 1 over X and passed through the
point 1 comma 0 that uniquely defined
this particular function the point being
what that this particular function since
the domain is for positive X 1 over X is
positive the curve is always rising
which means that the function itself
must be one-to-one and because the
function is one-to-one it means that the
inverse function exists this is no
different from any other example of
forming F inverse given a one-to-one
function called F so what we do is now
and remember how you invert this
function if you want to do this thing in
slow motion you first rotate this
through 90 degrees then flip it over if
you want to do it faster this the
inverse graph of this is the reflection
of this curve with respect to the line y
equals x in any event if we do this we
find that the graph of the function y
equals inverse log X is this particular
curve and notice the correspondence if
this is the point 1 comma 0 on the log
curve the inverse point is 0 comma 1 in
other words the inverse log of 0 is 1 ok
now the idea is something like this just
to have a review again of how see the
punch line I want to make for today's
lesson right at the beginning is that
the nice thing about studying inverse
functions is that once you know the
function of which
you're taking the inverse you
automatically get all the mileage you
want out of the inverse function well by
way of illustration if the function
natural log had the usual logarithmic
property we would suspect that its
inverse should have the usual
exponential property now what is the
usual exponential property the
exponential function is characterized by
what that if you take f of X 1 plus X 2
that's f of X 1 times f of X 2 so you
think of it in terms of the usual
exponential notation if you have say 10
raised to the X 1 plus X 2 power that's
the same as 10 to the X 1 power times 10
to the X 2 power in other words if our
Ln function is genuinely a logarithmic
function we would expect the inverse of
that function to be a genuine
exponential function and just to work
with inverses again let's see if this is
indeed true let's see if it's really
true that the inverse log of X 1 plus X
2 is the inverse log of X 1 times the
inverse log of X 2 see the whole idea is
what let's give these things names let
y1 be the inverse log of x1 and y2 be
the inverse log of x 2 now since we've
already studied the natural log function
the most natural thing to do here is to
invert these namely y1 equals the
inverse natural log of x1 is the same as
saying x1 is the natural log of Y 1 and
similarly this is the same as saying
that x2 is a natural log of Y 2 and now
we add equals to equals and we get 2 x1
plus x2 is natural log Y 1 plus natural
log Y 2 but allegedly we understand the
properties of the natural log because if
we didn't understand those there would
be kind of futile to be studying the
inverse function what do we know about
the natural log we know that the natural
log of y 1 times y 2 by definition of a
logarithmic function is log y 1 plus log
y 2 in other words natural log Y 1 plus
natural log Y 2 by the property of being
logarithmic is just a natural log of
I y2 and now taking this relationship
and inverting it to say this is the same
as saying what the inverse natural log
of x1 plus x2 is equal to y1 times y2
and if you now observe that y1 was the
inverse natural log of x1 and y2 is the
inverse natural log of X 2 we have the
result that we claimed we would have at
the beginning here now again here's one
example where it's not the result that
I'm not interested in but I'm interested
in showing again what we meant when we
said that once we learn a new concept we
can bring to it all of our old knowledge
see all of these things come from our
basic definition well let's carry on one
step further you see this was an
arithmetic property let's see if we can
get some calculus properties about the
inverse natural log based on our
knowledge of the natural log itself well
for example in a course of this type the
most natural thing to do I guess is
given any function we would always like
to be able to talk about derivative
provided of course the function is
differentiable so for example a typical
question that one might ask is find dy
DX if Y is inverse natural log X again
this works the same way as it did for
the inverse trig functions for the
inverse of everything that we've done so
far in this course we start with this
particular relationship and right away
translated into that which we're more
familiar with namely we translate y
equals the inverse natural log of X into
x equals natural log Y now you see again
since I know how to differentiate log Y
with respect to Y the derivative of
natural log Y with respect to Y was by
definition 1 over Y from this
relationship here I can find that the X
dy is 1 over Y ok and knowing that the x
dy is 1 over y using my inverse function
general theory that tells me that to
find the derivative of Y with respect to
X all I have to do is invert the
derivative of X with respect to Y I wind
up with the fact
that dy/dx is equal to Y itself in other
words the inverse log X function is
characterized by the fact that it's own
derivative in other words it's a non
destructible type of function with
respect to differentiation this is a
rather powerful property you see what
this thing says it says that the
derivative of Y with respect to X is y
itself by the way just as an aside we
can do the converse of this particular
problem you see we started with y equals
inverse log X and showed that this
particular equation was satisfied notice
that if we start with this particular
equation starting with dy/dx equals y
separate the variables and lo and behold
we wind up with dy over y equals DX and
without carrying out the details I leave
this to you because of this
straightforward notice that as we look
at the left-hand side here we hopefully
will think immediately of the natural
logarithm namely what do we want here
the function whose derivative with
respect to Y is 1 over Y again you see
what I'm saying is no still if we
started with this particular
differential equation we could have
shown that a logarithm and hence solving
for y explicitly would have led to the
inverse logarithm also but at any rate
notice then that we can find the
derivative of the inverse log just by
knowing how to find the derivative of
the natural log itself which is as we
expect things should be again and this
is a notational thing we do not use the
language in general inverse log X in
other words you know it's quite
conventional to talk about inverse sine
X you may notice that sometimes in the
text sometimes in my lectures I may have
used the word ox INEX but the general
general general notation is signed to
the minus 1 however when it comes to the
natural logarithm function the inverse
is usually not written as inverse
natural log X it's usually abbreviated
and let me say this by the symbol e to
the X now the reason I say by the symbol
is this
if I wanted to I can say look at if I've
never heard of exponents before let this
symbol be an abbreviation for inverse
log X does inverse log X exists yes I
even drew the graph of it at the
beginning of this particular lecture
however again if you are tempted to use
exponents the notation e to the X is in
keeping in line with the idea of our
previous lecture I say what this matches
the identification of natural log X with
the log of X to the base e remember in
our previous lecture we mentioned that
this particular function exists without
having to talk about a base but if you
wanted to identify it with a lot with a
traditional logarithm the base you would
have to pick is the base e where we
showed that a was some number between 2
& 4 in other words again it's just like
I D Y DX versus dy divided by DX and
other symbols that we invented this way
namely if I look at each of the X as
being the inverse of a natural log or
whether I look at it as being e raised
to the X power where E is that number
that someplace between 2 & 4 I don't get
into any trouble either way because of
the natural identification of choosing e
to be the base of my system but I just
mentioned that in passing now you see
the rest of today's lecture will go
fairly quickly and the reason that will
go fairly quickly is that once we've
established what the function is that
we're talking about every other property
of that function is going to follow from
the principles that we've already
learned for example in terms of our new
notation since the derivative of e to
the X with respect to X is e to the X
itself remember e to the X now can be
viewed as what e to the X power or to be
on safer grounds if you want to be
consistent it's just an abbreviation for
inverse natural log X but any rate if u
is now any differentiable function of X
notice that to find the derivative of e
to the U with respect to X by the chain
rule I can say what it's the derivative
of e to the U with respect to u times du
u DX we've just shown that the
derivative
either the U with respect to U is e to
the U again and therefore the derivative
of e to the U with respect to X is
either u times D u DX by the way this
again leads to another interesting thing
that makes integrals sort of tough to
handle in a way we've mentioned this
before but here's another nice natural
environment to bring this problem up and
again when we discussed the second
fundamental theorem of integral calculus
to show how one actually would have to
understand areas to be able to find a
function whose derivative was e to the
minus x squared we showed that there are
we mentioned we didn't prove it we
mentioned that there was no familiar
function whose derivative with respect
to X was e to the minus x squared so
this would be a very difficult problem
to handle now let's look at this one
instead let's look at integral 2x e to
the minus x squared DX to the untrained
eye it would appear that this is even
messier than this in other words this is
just e to the minus x squared
this one has either the minus x squared
with a 2x dangling in front of it and
that looks even tougher but notice that
if we look at our exponent minus x
squared the derivative or the
differential of minus x squared is what
it's minus 2x DX in other words the 2x
DX is precisely what you need to reduce
this to the form integral either you do
you in other words working this thing
out in more specific detail if I let u
equal minus x squared d u becomes minus
2x DX and therefore integral 2x e to the
minus x squared DX just becomes what
well the e to the minus x squared just
becomes e to the minus u and 2x DX is
just minus D u ok and you see this
substitution
I'm sorry u is minus x squared U is
minus x squared so minus x squared is U
so this becomes minus e to the UD u and
that of course is just minus see the
minus to come outside the integral of e
to the U with respect to U is just e to
the U
and since you is equal to minus
x-squared all we're saying is that if
you differentiate minus e to the minus x
squared you wind up with what to X e to
the minus x squared the reason being
that you must multiply this by the
derivative of the exponent with respect
to X the derivative the exponent is
minus 2 X minus 2 x times minus 1 is 2x
if you want to see this in more concise
differential notation you see what we're
saying is that the integral of e to some
power with respect to that same power is
e to that power plus a constant in other
words the function that one would have
to integrate e to the minus x squared
with respect to to wind up with e to the
minus x squared would be minus x squared
itself and you see now in the next step
since this is a true statement the
differential of minus x squared is minus
2x DX and now you see factoring out the
minus sign and multiplying through by
minus 1 we arrive at the same result
that we wound up with before but again
this is the kind of material that we can
drill on extensively in the exercises in
this particular unit the technique is
what that the basic building block of
the so-called exponential function the
inverse natural log is that when you
differentiate it you essentially do not
destroy it in other words the derivative
of e to the U with respect to the 2x is
e to the U times du u DX and I thought
that in closing today's lesson I might
as well show you a very powerful
application of this particular result in
a non-obvious situation and it's
something that we call second-order
differential equations I've picked out
here a differential equation let me just
show you what I have in mind over here
suppose I tell you that Y is a twice
differentiable function of X that
satisfies the following identity that
the second derivative of Y or respect to
X
- five times the first derivative of y
with respect to x plus 6 times y is
identically zero and the question is if
this equation is to be obeyed
what must Y be and a very interesting
technique for solving this kind of a
problem you see this is called a
second-order differential equation
because the highest derivative that
appears is the second derivative okay a
rather powerful technique using the
exponential is available to us for
problems of this sort and the idea
hinges on this as a trial solution which
I'll call Y sub T let's try e to the rx
where R happens to be a constant you see
the whole idea is if I differentiate e
to the RX with respect to X I get e to
the rx back again only with the factor
of R namely the derivative of my
exponent in this case see R is a
constant the derivative of our X with
respect to X is just R so notice that
the first derivative of Y sub T with
respect to X is our e to the rx the
second derivative of Y sub T with
respect to X is what R is a constant I
differentiate e to the rx that brings
down another factor of R and leaves me
with e to the rx you see the whole idea
being notice that e to the rx is a
common factor of Y sub 2 y sub T prime Y
sub T double prime if I now substitute
these results back into my original
equation look what I wind up with y
double prime becomes R squared e to the
rx minus 5y prime that's minus 5r e to
the RX plus 6y 6 e to the RX and that
must equal 0 and here's the key point e
to the rx is now a common factor i
factor that out ok if the product of two
numbers is 0 one of the factors must be
0 but notice from our graph of the
exponential the inverse logarithm e to
the X e to the rx can never be negative
and could never be 0 in fact e the Rx is
always positive therefore if e to the rx
is always positive it must be the other
factor
which is zero but R squared minus 5r
plus 6 is not a second-order
differential equation it's a
second-degree polynomial equation it's a
familiar quadratic equation which I can
solve quite easily in other words I find
what that R must be either 2 or R must
equal 3 in other words my claim is that
either e to the 2x or e to the 3x must
be a solution of this particular
equation of course we can do more with
that which we will in a later part of
calculus not in this packages work but
we're not going to study differential
equations in great detail here but for
our present purposes I think this
illustrates how one can use the fact
that it's a rather powerful structural
property when the derivative of a
function with respect to X is the
function itself by the way as a quick
check you notice that if y equals e to
the 2x y prime is twice either the 2x Y
double prime is 4 e to the 2x and
therefore Y double prime minus 5 y prime
plus 6y is what it's for e to the 2x
minus 10 e to the 2x plus 6 e to the 2x
and that in fact is genuinely
identically 0 in a similar way checking
out y equals e to the 3x we get Y prime
is 3 e to the 3x y double prime is 9 e
to the 3x therefore 9 e to the 3x minus
15 a to the 3x plus 6 e to the 3x is
again identically 0 and again you see
what this powerful technique is in
general if a and B are constants the
substitution Y sub t equals e to the r e
to the RX and there'll be a problem in
the exercises on this to give you
additional drill but that substitution
transforms the second-order differential
equation y double prime plus ay Y prime
plus B y equals 0 into an equivalent
quadratic equation R squared plus a R
plus B equals 0 and you see from this
equation you
the quadratic formula we can find the
values of R that satisfy this and that
gives us a couple of solutions to the
equation well any rate I deliberately
want this lecture to stay short to make
the most important impact and that is
again what that once we knew what the
natural log function was and we define
the inverse natural log function
everything that we wanted to know about
the inverse natural log followed from
the properties of the log itself and
this is basically the lesson for today
we will continue the discussion of
exponential functions from a different
point of view in our next lecture but
until that next lecture goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate